[Music]
may the porks be with you once again my
night went to a galaxy far far away when
JJ Abrams's Mark Hamill and Neal Scanlan
all showed up to the Oscar Wilde award
did you expect like the pork still blow
up as much as they did no no doing the
porks actually was terrifying because
you have a fear that if you get it wrong
or you know all the fans again to sort
of hate you forever quite frankly so it
was great to eat you know as soon as we
heard that you know there was a warm
reaction to that it was great I mean I
incredibly lovable I don't mean that
because it has anything to do with me
they just come across in the film which
we haven't talked since the last Jedi
came out so talk to me about your
experience like you have a favorite
creature that maybe we didn't see until
the movie was out not really I still
like to see what I call the sea sail
which I just I like that scene just
because I think it's it's just a great
moment in the film I you know with with
Luke couldn't with the with Rey and the
whole thing that we shot that in Ireland
we shot in a real location it just as I
have lots of fun memories of shooting
that secret so when I see it in the film
somehow I don't know each other it
brings back all those memories so it's a
nice segue into what tonight is about so
what does it mean to be here kind of
supporting this organization it's
fantastic I mean it's just it's
wonderful to be here it's wonderful to
be part of it as well it would be
inviting it's it's just right it's just
an yeah I'm here holding up that side of
it absolutely yeah practical effects
you're in town because I believe her in
town because you've got a big event on
Sunday what is it what is it who knows
again it's just wonderful to be part of
it who knows a I either which way it's
it's a great event it's great to be back
here and yeah I enjoy
how will you celebrate if you win try
and make it through the night I think is
the best way of looking at it isn't it
absolutely yeah yeah yeah iiiii it's
your ticket your is your ticket to the
parties isn't it so you you know
everybody who wins good on them your
plus-one okay
[Music]